hey what's up guys it's Rob and welcome
to my tutorial for thee 16.8 in just
stone I've gotten a lot of requests for
the 16 pointed ninja star and I figured
since I already have tutorials for the
four pointed ones and also some eight
pointed ones that this would be the next
step up the ninja star arsenal the good
thing about it is that it's really easy
to make and it's super cool looking so I
don't think anyone's going to have any
trouble but one thing about it is that
it comes apart really easy so if you
want to throw it later on you're going
to have to tape it up this is one that I
made out of origami paper and I taped it
together so it doesn't come apart for
the red and blue one I use colored paper
eight-and-a-half by eleven letter size
but you can use any size square sheet
that you want so once you have the paper
you're ready to go the sixteen pointed
ninja star just like the transforming
ninja star is a type of modular origami
model which means it's made up of a
whole bunch of these individual units
that slide into one another or fit
together in order to get the ninja star
the transforming ninja star is made up
of eight pieces instead of sixteen but
the really cool thing about it is that
you can take it from this frisbee
conformation and you could push on the
outsides like this in order to get a
ninja star just like that I think it's
really cool it flies nicely and it's
easy to make I have a tutorial for it
that you can check out by clicking on
this little button or link up here that
will take you to the video because each
of the pieces of the sixteen pointed
ninja star are made the exact same way
I'm going to go through with you how to
make two of them and then you can make
the rest and I'll show you how to
interlock them if you're using letter
sized paper like I am then we need to
convert it into a square so we take this
corner and fold it across that the top
edge is aligned with the left side once
it's neatly aligned you can make a
crease on the outside and then we could
tear off or cut off this excess paper
here if you're using square paper then
you don't need to make this diagonal
fold so you could begin here take the
top edge now and then you could fold it
down to the bottom edge once it's neatly
lined up then you can make a crease
along the top of the paper
now you can open up the paper and you'll
see that we have this horizontal line
here in the middle we're going to rotate
the paper so that that line is now
vertical and then we're going to take
both of the top corners and fold them
directly into the middle just like we
would for an airplane so just fold it in
so that the top is aligned with that
middle line then you can make a crease
on the outside do the same with the left
side take the top corner fold it
directly into the middle and then make a
crease we're also going to do this for
both of the bottom corners so if you
want to rotate it around just like that
then you could do the same take the top
corner fold it in and then make a crease
on the outside the last one fold it in
and then make a crease now what we're
going to do is we're going to take both
of these bottom edges here and we're
going to fold them directly into the
middle on that vertical line also so you
want to take this bottom edge and fold
it in you might need to round this off a
little bit and just fold it in like this
so that this corner is also directly in
the middle once you line it up neatly
then you can make a crease on the
outside do the same with the other
bottom edge fold it in line it up with
the middle
and then make a crease on the outside so
now it should look something like this
now what we're going to do is we're
going to turn over the model and we're
going to fold this point down until we
see these edges align with the top of
the crease that we're going to make so
we basically want to crease it along
this the top of these two edges so flip
it over fold it down make sure it lines
up with the top of those two edges and
also the tip of the paper should be
directly on that vertical crease once
it's like that then you can make a
crease along the top so it should look
like this
then what we're going to do is we're
going to take both sides of the paper
and we're going to fold them down away
from us just like that just want to take
both edges fold them down and then make
a crease and make sure the entire piece
is nice and flat and that's it that's
how to make one of the units I'm going
to quickly go through with the red one
if you want to see how they're
interlocked all you need to do is to go
to this time down here take the top edge
and fold it down to the bottom edge make
a crease open it up fold both of these
corners into that vertical line
for both of the bottom corners now into
the middle
fold both of the bottom edges into the
middle
flip the paper over and then you're
going to fold this tip down until the
edge is flush or aligned at the top of
these two edges there make a crease and
then fold both sides down away from you
once you finish making all 16 units then
you're ready to interlock them and I
didn't say this before but if you do
want it to have alternating colors like
the one that I have you just need to
make eight of one color and eight of
another color if you take a look at the
pieces you'll notice that each one has
two pockets here and they also have two
tips you're going to take the tips of
one piece and slide them into the
pockets of another one so just kind of
squeeze down on it like that
and make sure that both of them go into
the pockets of the other piece and then
you could push it in all the way until
it doesn't go anymore
then again I'm going to take a blue
piece now take it squeeze it together
until both of the tips go into the
pockets and then push it in all the way
and that's how to interlock it it's
really easy and I think we should
probably fast-forward this a little bit
[Music]
so once you've finished interlocking
them all then we just need to make sure
that the last one fits in properly then
you just need to round it off by kind of
pushing all around just like this so as
you'll notice if you do move it around a
little bit it's going to come apart so
what I'm going to do is to tape it
together and the way that I do this is I
just put some tape on the inside of the
ninja star in this middle ring and I'm
going to put it sideways so I'm sure you
guys can figure this out you know you
don't have to watch me do the whole
thing so let's speed it up a little bit
[Music]
all right so there you go as you can see
I used eight pieces of tape you just
want to make sure that each of these
individual joints are taped together you
might want to use the transparent tape
because it looks a little nicer but
there you go now it's stuck together so
when I throw it I found that if you
throw it vertically by taking it in
between two of your fingers like this
and flicking it out like that it
actually flies pretty good so let's give
it a shot
it also flies really good just throwing
it over hand like this if you want to
try throwing it with your hand in the
middle like this like a disc
that'll work also I hope you guys enjoy
the video be sure to rate and subscribe
sometimes you might be wondering if you
can get more than 16 pieces in the knit
ninja star and the answer is yes you can
I actually put 20 pieces together but
let me know how many you're able to get
I have some ideas and requests for
tutorials that I'd like to do in the
future but leave me a comment below let
me know what you'd like to see the most
I also want to get my portrait video out
that my friend did and I'm also going to
be updating my Rob's phone channel
really soon so be sure to check it out
so where was I for the last couple of
months well a lot of people came up with
some really creative comments on my last
video and here are the most popular I'll
see you later guys
[Music]
you